this video is sponsored by squarespace
the best way to make an amazing website
hey guys it's max
in front of me i have two powerful
laptops i have apple's new macbook pro
with the m1 processor and 16 gigs of ram
and i have the zephyrus g14
which has amd's best current laptop
processor the 4900
hs and it's also equipped with an nvidia
2060
and in this video we will finally see
how does an
amd processor the best one they have for
laptops stack up against the m1
we're gonna be running multiple
different benchmarks we're also gonna be
running
real-world tests such as photo editing
video editing
we're gonna talk about ram differences
and we'll also talk about heat and
thermals using our awesome thermal
camera we know that the m1 macbooks
smoked the intel processors even the 16
inch
but we have to give amd a chance now i'm
going to start out with
turning on both of these systems and
both of them do have
fingerprint readers built into the power
buttons it looks like the mac was
only about a second longer so not a big
difference
and now let's do awake from sleep test
so open it up
the m1 mac is auto on compared to this
which took about
three four seconds not that big of a
difference
but it still is really nice i've been
using this
uh mac at home and it's awesome just
open it up and you're instantly in
and i want to compare the actual laptops
themselves now the point of this video
isn't to compare
the g14 against the macbook it's to
compare amd's processor and nvidia
graphics
but i still want to take a quick second
to compare them the g14 even though it
is marketed as a gaming ultrabook it is
quite a bit
thicker it is heavier 3.6 pounds
compared to
three and the whole design is just a lot
more
chunky now it makes sense because of the
power that's in this machine we have
vents everywhere and as soon as you open
up the lid
it actually lifts the bottom up from the
table even though it has
feet to allow airflow even when it's
closed
but you could tell with all these vents
all around that they're trying to move
as much air as possible to get the best
performance out of it
which is going to be interesting once we
check out the temperatures
now as far as ports we have a massive
difference
with the macbook pro we have two usb
type 4 ports that are also backwards
compatible with thunderbolt 3
we have no thunderbolt ports on the g14
but we have
an hdmi usb 10 gigabit that also does
display port output
headphone jack power brick with a little
barrel plug because it needs a lot of
power
and then the other side we have another
usb and two more usb
uh super speed regular ports so a lot
more ports as far as the build quality
the g14 is very plasticky
even though plastic doesn't feel bad it
definitely doesn't feel as nice as
aluminum
and i do want to point out we have some
gamer touches like these little leds
that are in here that you can customize
which are very cool
so of course the g14 is a gaming
ultrabook compared to a more
kind of professional regular type of
laptop so we are going to have design
differences
as you guys can see with the keyboards
here we have a gamer type
looking keyboard and it actually feels
quite a bit better than i expected
but still not as good as apple's magic
keyboard
and then the track pads i've actually
been using this for a bit it is
terrible most gamers are not going to
use the trackpad but even for regular
web browsing it sucks compared to the
excellent trackpad
on the macbook pro and now let's quickly
touch on the displays there is a massive
difference
the g14 display is designed for gamers
it's a matte display
it's not as bright the contrast and
colors are not color accurate for
editing and it's a 120 hertz panel as
well so i can't directly compare it
mainly we have this laptop because it's
super popular and it has that really
nice amd chip with a good graphics
chip the macbook pro it's a glossy
display sharper
brighter color accurate way better
contrast and colors
now along with that we actually don't
have a webcam on this laptop so you're
gonna have to purchase an external one
whereas the macbook pro has one it's not
amazing but they have made it better now
before we do a speaker comparison and
get into performance let me give a shout
out to the sponsor of this video
squarespace if you've been thinking
about making your own website
squarespace is seriously the best way to
go
we've built multiple websites and you
can too with literally
no web making experience it's incredibly
simple it's affordable
and ours have been running flawlessly
for years now and bringing in new
clients
thanks to its built-in seo tools so
whether you need a website for
a small business or literally anything
else go to squarespace.commaxtech for a
free
no credit card required trial or click
the link down below
and when you're ready to launch you can
save 10 off your first purchase of a
website or domain alright guys go ahead
and put on a pair of headphones
and let's take a listen
all right guys let me know your thoughts
down in the comment section below i'll
let you guys know what i heard and i
have to say i'm actually pleasantly
surprised
by the g14 now i'm sure the macbook pro
is a little bit louder
it does sound better in pretty much
every way but i was expecting
this gaming machine to have terrible
speakers like most gaming laptops do
and now let's start getting into
performance and i'm super excited
because we're going to test multiple
metrics
now i want to do a baseline reading on
temperatures and also talk about battery
life i'm going to go ahead and plug
the g14 in because we want to maintain
full performance and we are going to
test
unplug performance as well with that the
ac adapter
is massive it's 180 watts compared to 61
watts
on the macbook and that's because you
need the extra performance for the
graphics card and possibly the cpu
so let's go ahead and plug it in now i
wish we could do a battery life
comparison like we did against the
16-inch
but before i plug it in i just want to
go over battery so far what we got i
started 100
about half hour ago just doing you know
having these open
we're at 89 now and it says we have six
hours remaining which is probably
true for very simple use let me go and
pop this one
in and as far as the macbook we actually
started at 88
and now we're at 86 so the new m1 max
are super power efficient
and just to give you guys a point of
reference in the 16 inch comparison
after three and a half hours of
rendering photo editing video
editing everything that we tested it
only used about 33
battery compared to 16 inch which died
completely
so that is incredible and now let's get
a baseline reading with our thermal
camera which i have linked below
looks like the hottest spot is about 28
degrees it's actually the lcd display
and we have some really cool spots where
the fans are which is really cool to see
now switching to the mac it's much more
even
and the hottest spots only 24 degrees
celsius on the keyboard now our cpu
temperatures are almost identical
at about 30 to 33 degrees but one
difference is that the macbooks fan
is actually off and there is just one
fan whereas with the g14
the dual fans are running at 2600 rpm
and sitting here i can actually hear the
fans are
on ever since i opened up the machine
now i am
in the performance mode we can go down
to the silent mode
which that lowers the performance of the
system but interestingly when we do that
the fan speeds don't drop by that much
and you can still hear it in a quiet
room
we do also have the turbo mode and there
the fans definitely ramp up and they
start getting annoying and moving
forward i'm gonna keep it in that turbo
mode
to make sure we get the best performance
and now let's compare the ssds
the new macs got faster ssds with the
new controller
and with the g14 we actually have a user
replaceable ssd and this one has a one
terabyte
compared to 512 bam all right so even
though the capacity is double looks like
uh write speed is very similar slightly
faster on the mac by about 100
but as far as the read speed it is about
700 megabytes per second faster
and now let's do a web browsing test
since a lot of us spend a lot of time on
the web i'm using speedometer test here
and here i have microsoft's edge browser
compared to
safari and in a sec we're also going to
test out chrome on both systems
all right we have our results and we
have 140 compared to 220
runs per minute now 140 is actually a
pretty good result
and now let's go ahead and close these
and we'll also run it
in chrome we got just a little bit
slower than edge we have 130
and then we have 209 so once again a
little bit slower than safari so
ultimately this really shows you that
you get a lot better performance for web
browsing on these macs
and now let's run our first cpu test
we're using the latest version of
geekbench 5 that has been now
updated and as you guys can see right
here
our maximum frequency is 4.4 gigahertz
at least what geekbench is saying
compared to 3.2
we both are actually eight core
processors but
the amd has eight high performance cores
compared to
four power efficient and then four
performance cores all right we are done
and wow finally some competition
as far as the single core we have 12 18
compared to 17
30 that is 42 higher single core
performance and maybe that's why we're
getting much snappier web browsing and
simple tasks but as far as multi-core
we have 7923 compared to 7533 so
the g14 is about five percent more
powerful in terms of multi-core
performance with a variety of tasks oh
by the way
the macbook is unplugged with all of
these tests we don't have it plugged
into power
so i want to go ahead and run this one
more time and it looks like we can no
longer be in the turbo mode we're now in
the performance mode
here we go and that is a huge difference
in single core performance
literally the macbook on battery power
is about 2.4 times
faster in single core tasks now as far
as the multi-core it actually didn't
drop
as much as i expected we're at 54.49
so that means that the m1 mac is about
38
faster just going off of battery power
and now let's compare the graphics
performance this machine's plugged in
again we're back
into the turbo mode i can hear the fans
so let's go ahead and run this all right
we have our scores
and wow okay that nvidia card is
powerful
we have 75 400 compared to
21 600 so that is what close to four
times the performance three and a half
times the performance or something like
that
it's gonna be interesting to see how
this affects real world performance such
as video
editing now i also ran it unplugged in
the performance mode
and there it actually scored 26
000 so still higher than the graphics
that's in the m1 mac
even when we have it unplugged and now
let's really push these machines to
their limits using cinebench r20 which
is going to max out the cpus
and give us our total raw performance
let's go ahead and hit run it's going to
be a 10 minute stress test
right away the cpu spike to 4.3
gigahertz
but now it's down to about 4 gigahertz
that's interesting
the max at 70 with the fan still off the
mac
is also running at 3.2 gigahertz which
is its peak
now another big difference that we have
is wattage
the m1 chip only uses 13
watts to achieve this performance level
and we're at about 53.6
about 54 watts for the 8 core processor
in the g14
about a minute in the mac just turned on
its fan it's running at 1200 rpms 11.89
so basically the slowest speed it could
possibly run at
all right wow this is interesting about
two and a half minutes into the test
the wattage dropped down to about 35
watts instead of 54 and because of that
our temperatures also drop down to 74
celsius which is quite
cool it seems like amd doesn't want to
run their chips as hot as
intel does we're five minutes in about
halfway done so i busted out the thermal
camera
and the asus looks to be peaking at
about
37 38 degrees celsius and the
m1 mac 37 degrees
right in the center there probably where
the chipset is at
now as far as internal cpu temperatures
our mac is at 92 degrees
celsius we just got the updated tg fan
pro
which is combining everything and
showing us actually i think the peak
temperature
and it's interesting to see that the
efficiency cores are only about seven
degrees celsius
whereas the performance ones are about
90 to 92. it looks like
apple would rather keep this machine
silent
but a little bit hotter instead of
what asus is doing where the fans are
much louder they're audible
and they instead are turning down the
frequency we're running at about 3.3
gigahertz
and another thing that i noticed is i
put my hand here it's way hotter than
here
and we're actually getting hot air
coming out from the g14 that's getting
sucked in from the side
into the mac um so that probably makes
sense why it's running hotter this time
around than our previous tests all right
we have our results and amd
you're on another level our max scored
76.86 which is actually lower than we
got before
the g14 it scored 99.88
that is 30 higher than the score that we
got with the m1 powered
mac so looks like the m1 has finally met
its match
now of course we are plugged in here so
let me go ahead and unplug this i'm just
going to do one quick run not a long
term throttling test
getting started looks like we boosted up
to 2.6
now 2.9 basically three gigahertz and as
far as the wattage
we're looking at about 25 watts and our
one run test is
done and we have 85 60 so it's still 11
higher performance than the m1 mac that
is fantastic performance
and now let's talk about gaming i am
going to run a test here using gfx bench
the same exact benchmark so i'm going to
go ahead and hit start
here and gaming is where a windows
system
is going to come ahead if you care about
gaming you have all games available
the scores are in and honestly i was
expecting a bigger
difference we have 81 frames per second
on the mac
and 119.8 on the
g14 now that is obviously a big
difference
47 higher frames per second so it is
significant
but if we take a look at the metal test
in geekbench 5
and metal and then the cuda test the g14
was about 350
faster instead of 47 so i think for
certain graphics
things like this for gaming the metal is
just so optimized with that graphics
ship which is designed
to work together really well but of
course let's jump into some other real
world tests
and we'll see what difference we get
let's jump into photo editing
i have lightroom classic opened up on
both
with the same exact library and files
here and one thing i have to note is
that
live classic is not optimized for apple
chips it's x86 optimized
so for the amd processor here and it's
running rosetta to translate it on the
mac which lowers performance
but let's go ahead and open this up i'm
going to zoom in on these 42 megapixel
files
from the a7r3 it's actually
pretty much instant on both of them no
issues some systems
will end up lagging here and i have a
ton of corrections made
on all of these images now let's go
ahead and switch
between these and each time i switch
here it has to make a ton of different
changes
to the raw images and it looks to be
about the same actually the last couple
the mac is actually slightly faster at
changing which i didn't expect let's
test out brush performance
and that is pretty smooth right there
let's try it again a little bit of lag
at the start and of course we are
plugged in on the g14
on the mac also a little bit of lag at
the start and then it smooths out but of
course this is
a lot of changes being made at one time
and now we're going to export
50 of these raw images to jpeg i'm going
to hit export here and start my timer
and i want to mention that in this photo
editing test this is the first time that
i noticed the fans actually ramping up
and down and modulating
which is kind of annoying in the
previous test we didn't notice that
we're 45 seconds in
and this is interesting the mac is quite
a bit ahead on the export
then the amd and we are in the turbo
mode we're plugged
in i was not expecting this especially
because
this application is designed for x86 for
the amd and intel processors
alright wow the m1 mac is done
i actually heard the fans spinning up
there towards the end so this is really
pushing the machine to its limits it's
using both the cpu maxing it out
and it's using graphics as well which is
why i was expecting the amd system
to smoke it in this test all right it is
done
the g14 took three minutes and 14
seconds
compared to two minutes and 38 seconds
for the m1
mac 23 faster
which is mind-blowing because it did so
not silently but much quietly it did on
battery power
and this application is not optimized
yet
for the apple silicon processor and now
let's get into video editing i
am using davinci resolve here not
premiere or final cut
premiere is slower on both the amd
system and the mac
obviously final cut is quick but it's
mac only so we're gonna be starting out
with stabilizing a 4k
clip now the graphics card in here the
nvidia should be
really well used with cuda it is flying
along where 50
compared to 20 here bam it got done
the g14 took only 16 seconds
the m1 mac took 39 seconds so more than
twice as long let's go ahead and open up
a standard
4k project this is a full 4k timeline
here we have two lots applied
we have film grain applied and in the
past with the previous
intel based macbook pros it would be a
stuttery mess it would not play back at
all
now it's playing back perfectly smoothly
of course
with the 2060 is also playing back
perfectly
smoothly now i also want to go ahead and
unplug
the system it's going to switch over to
performance mode instead of
turbo mode the fans slow down and now
our graphics card is
maxed out and it looks like you guys see
all the stuttering here
on battery power it is no longer able
to play this back you guys can see this
is about five
seven frames per second instead of 30
and that's interesting because
the cuda score unplugged is actually
higher than the m1
maybe it's just optimization or
efficiency so let's go ahead and plug
this thing
back in and now let's do an export test
this is a five minute project
and the beauty with this nvidia graphics
card is that we can go ahead and switch
over
from cpu encoding or amd which isn't
that good to the nvidia
and the new rtx graphics cards have very
good
and very fast encoders all right wow
so about halfway done there the fans
just ramped up
incredibly loud that's probably because
we're maxing out the cpu
oh it kicked up even more there okay
i've never heard the fans run this loud
on the system
it's like a hair dryer now 80 degrees
celsius we're using a lot of cpu we're
maxing out the gpu right now and it is
trying to stay cool
the g14 is completed
and since we still have a ways to go on
the mac i'm gonna go ahead and unplug
this
and i'm gonna go ahead and run this one
more time to see
what performance we get if you don't
have access
to a wall outlet alright the macbook
just finished and it looks like it took
five minutes and two seconds
compared to two minutes and 46 seconds
so not twice as fast for the g14 on
battery
but getting close to that and i also
want to point out that
when we ran this exact same test in
final cut it took three minutes and four
seconds
so the g14 is still slightly faster
even with final cut running on here it's
pretty close and of course that is
plugged in
now i have this test running right now
unplugged
so far it's been about two minutes and
it looks like we have about 10 minutes
remaining
unplugged you go from 2 minutes 46
seconds
to about 12 minutes compared to about
five
in davinci resolve and now let's take a
look at what a lot of you guys asked
about and that is black magic
raw we're skipping the 4k we're going
straight to 6k here i have a timeline
open
and i actually have some luts applied
here as well
let's go ahead and hit play as you guys
could see
it's playing back perfectly on the g14
24 frames per second whereas on the m1
we're getting stutters now i was
expecting this to play back better
because as far as decoding the 6k it can
do it just fine but i'm guessing it's
because
our graphics card is actually maxed out
at 99
right now probably because we have
multiple luts and color corrections
applied
so this clip right here is just the raw
6k
footage and as you guys can see it is
playing back
perfectly smoothly so it looks like we
just don't have enough raw graphics
performance to be able to decode
the 6k footage and apply multiple luts
the base correction whereas
with the 2060 we're using 89
93 90 of the raw graphics performance
to play back perfectly smoothly and keep
in mind this thing has about three and a
half times better
raw graphics performance but as far as
4k black magic raw
let's go ahead and play this back i have
the corrections and i have two let's
apply here the m1 is actually playing
about perfectly
as is uh the g14 so as far as video
editing performance if you're gonna be
using davinci resolve or premiere pro
you are better off
with a system like this that has the
best amd processor and a dedicated
nvidia graphics chip
as long as you're plugged in that is on
the go you'll actually still get faster
performance from
a mac and now for our final conclusion
does an
amd bass system with dedicated graphics
beat out the m1
mac and the answer is yes
at least if you're plugged into the wall
of course i'm using the very best
laptop cpu that they have and with that
the rtx 2060 is very
powerful and the m1 mac it sips power
it's quiet it's fairly cool and it
performs great for what it is and this
is
apple's lowest and slowest apple silicon
chip so we have a lot more coming up in
the future
so you guys go ahead and let me know
what your thoughts were did any of this
really surprise you i know lightroom i
was really surprised by
and then the performance when you unplug
i want to hear your guys's thoughts
and you guys can click above to
subscribe if you guys are wondering how
this performs compared to intel and
video editing with final cut we'll have
some great videos right over there
we have links to both down below thank
you guys for watching has been max and
i'll see you in the next video